Speaker 1: You can also participate for free
in The David Pakman Show subreddit, which
now has nearly 33000 subscribers.
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit is the place
to find it a few interesting and disturbing
posts I found this morning on the subreddit
user kitto four five nine wrote.
My wife won't get vaccinated.
David sir.
My wife is anti-vax, not just for COVID, but
all vaccines.
She was, of course, vaccinated as a kid, but
due to online propaganda, she won't take the
COVID vaccine and doesn't want our kids to
be vaccinated at all.
Any ideas how I can change her mind and before
you say it?
I've already tried withholding sex that only
seemed to encourage her.
I really don't have advice.
I don't know how folks end up with someone
with views so diametrically opposed to their
own.
Now there are some people who have recently
said, My spouse won't let the kids be vaccinated.
Who said I really had no idea.
I mean, it's not like my spouse is a right
wing nut.
It's not like my spouse has been a conspiracy
theorist in some other way.
It came out of nowhere.
They're just against the COVID vaccine.
That seems to me like it would be relatively
rare.
I mean, I guess it's possible that you really
didn't.
There was no sign whatsoever, but you would
imagine that there were probably some signs
that maybe people didn't notice.
I don't know.
But unfortunately, I don't have advice.
I don't have advice.
It sounds like an extremely, extremely difficult
situation, which I do not envy.
I know that a couple of parents called in
during live calls a few weeks ago, maybe a
couple of months, and said, I'm thinking of
secretly having the kids vaccinated.
I'm going to withhold that information from
my spouse because they will go nuts and I
am determined to get our kid or kids vaccinated.
That these would be decisions for one to make.
But I do not envy the situation.
User scheme ahead is taking issue with the
term vaccine skeptic.
A scheme had rates the term skeptic should
not be applied to those still hesitant to
take the COVID vaccine.
Skeptics form their opinions based on evidence,
and there's more than enough evidence at this
point showing that the COVID vaccines are
safe and effective.
People who are still hesitant to take the
vaccine are not hesitant because of skepticism,
but for other reasons.
Maybe irrational fear may be misinformation.
Maybe my freedoms, but not due to skepticism.
I think we should stop using the term vaccine
skeptic.
I agree.
First of all, hesitant is often not accurate
because they're not really hesitant.
They're just not doing it.
Hesitant would be like, Oh, I'm about to jump
into the pool, but I'm hesitating because
it's going to be cold.
But then I do it right.
I hesitated, but I did it.
A lot of this vaccine hesitancy is just people
aren't doing it, no matter what.
And then I agree we do need a sort of more
a tougher term.
I don't know what the term would be, but I
agree that it feels weird to say vaccine skeptic
or vaccine hesitant because it simply doesn't
accurately describe what's going on.
And then lastly, a few people writing to me
and posting about this article an article
on FiveThirtyEight, which says it looks like
House Democrats are worried about the 2022
midterms.
You can check out the article on FiveThirtyEight
by Nathaniel Rakic, and it outlines how there
are a number of House members that are leaving
office and how that is going to impact the
balance potentially, and the many reasons
that Democrats maybe are worried about 2022.
And there's no shortage of reasons to be worried.
It's it would be the correct reaction you
if you accurately and honestly assess the
circumstances for the midterms, Democrats
should be worried, and many Democrats are
in general midterms after a new party takes
control of the White House.
Don't go well for that party.
Since Joe Biden is a Democrat and won the
White House, you would just historically it's
almost always the case that you would expect
Democrats not to do well in the midterms.
You also have because of their retirements
and people leaving to do other things to run
for mayor.
Senate different things that also potentially
is going to be a problem for Democrats.
So yeah, Democrats should be worried about
2022, and we're going to be talking about
it extensively.
We already have been.
To some degree, it makes sense and we'll get
we'll dig into that more, probably really
as soon as next week.
Join the discussion on the subreddit at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit